here's a chart of unemployment in the
u.s. it's pretty good the unemployment
rate is down to five percent a
seven-year low but dig a little deeper
into the report and you'll see how far
the economy is from achieving truly full
employment the jobless rate for
african-americans was nine point four
percent in November that's higher than
the white jobless rate was when it
peaked in October November of 2009 and
unemployment is considered a national
crisis other groups continue to have
high jobless rates as well people with
disabilities people with less than a
high school education and Hispanics
discrimination appears to be a factor
the unemployment rate for people with
only a high school degree is more than
twice as high as the rate for people
with a bachelor's degree but blacks with
bachelor's degrees actually have the
same unemployment rate is white with
only high school degrees the question
for the Federal Reserve is what to do
about this the some economists say what
the US needs is a high-pressure economy
something like what we have now where
the unemployment rate is so low that
employers are forced we look more
closely candidates they would ordinarily
pass over they say the whole country
would benefit if more people were more
productive if this were a desert island
we'd want everybody collecting coconuts
other economists worried that a high
pressure economy with loose nothing but
wage inflation one thing's for sure as
the Fed prepares for mid December rate
increase the jobless worried that their
last best hope for paying work is
slipping away